[Music]
6 25 on your veterans day wednesday was
driving you crazy how about an hov
question
an hov question about motorcycles our
buddy donald writes in you know what
size for the hov lane on the 95 north
off the i-15 they do say
motorcycles okay but do motorcycles have
to have two riders every other sign says
two or more people
he says i've called the nhp haven't
gotten a response well donald here is
your answer it comes from one of those
posters that end up put out when the hov
policy was changing
back when good old project neon was
wrapping up so on the left side of the
poster they talk about which vehicles
are allowed to use the hov lanes
right underneath the vehicles with two
or more people it does say motorcycles
and under that
in teeny tiny letters it says even if
only
one person so go ahead and ride that
motorcycle all by your lonesome on the
hov lanes donald thanks for writing
we've got that poster and tons more
information on our website eight newsnow
dot com click traffic then driving me
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy